It's been just over twelve years since the first
Twilight film exploded across movie screens.
Despite the series' status as a box-office
powerhouse, there are plenty of questionable
instances in the films that you might
have missed when you were a teenager.
Before he first appeared in the
Twilight series as Jacob Black,
Bella's second love interest and burgeoning
werewolf, actor Taylor Lautner was best known
for his role in The Adventures of Sharkboy
and Lavagirl. Jacob wasn't a major character
in the first Twilight film, but one
detail stands out during his scenes.
Jacob's character initially has long
hair that reaches past his shoulders.
Since Lautner had short hair, he had to
wear a pretty obvious wig for the role.
Team Jacob teens might've been able to turn
a blind eye to the hairpiece when the first
film was released, but it's pretty hard to miss as
an adult. Not only was the wig super-noticeable,
but Lautner said that the wig also caused
numerous technical issues on set. Whenever
stray hairs would fly into his face the crew
would have to cut and start the scene over.
Lautner also said there was mutual
hatred between him and his wig,
and that he didn't miss it after
the series ended. Luckily for him,
Jacob's character cropped his hair after his
transformation into a werewolf in New Moon,
so he was able to part ways with the wig for
the rest of the series. According to Lautner,
they even gave the wig its own round of
applause when its role officially wrapped.
This is more of a fun "blink and you'll miss it"
sort of goof, but it becomes more obvious when you
rewatch the series as an adult. Shortly after
Bella first meets Edward at Forks High School,
Edward comes to her rescue when a van careens
toward her in the school parking lot. In the
scene, Bella is shocked at the impossibility
of Edward's actions, from darting across the
parking lot instantly to stopping the force of
the van with his arm. It's one of the pair's
first encounters, and also the first hint for
Bella that Edward is not your average teenager.
But one detail that bothers viewers is a small
prop in this scene. Just before the van spins out
of control, Bella is putting things into her
backpack -- which is on the hood of her car.
While Edward prevents the van from crushing
Bella, it still hits the back of her truck
with considerable force. However, when the
film cuts to a wider shot of the parking lot
as students rush to check on Bella, the
backpack is still in the exact place it
was before the crash. In a real life scenario,
her bag probably would have been sent flying or
would have at least fallen to the ground.
This was most likely a continuity error,
or Bella must have had a super strong magnet
in her backpack that held it in place.
A huge plot point in the Twilight books is that
while Bella wants to sleep with Edward, he refuses
to do so until they get married. Repressed desire
also exists in other forms in the Twilight saga:
the Cullens naturally desire human blood but
cannot drink it, while Edward is naturally
drawn to Bella because she's the only person who
can resist his ability to read people's thoughts.
Edward's reasoning for not wanting to sleep
with Bella has to do with his superhuman vampire
strength: He believes his desire is dangerous
for Bella, and that he could actually hurt her.
Edward's views are not that surprising
given some context about his creator.
The author of the Twilight books, Stephenie
Meyer, is a devout Mormon and has said that
her characters exhibit her own beliefs
and feelings about premarital relations.
Even actor Robert Pattinson, who portrayed Edward
in the films, agreed that despite the steamy
chemistry between him and his co-star Kristen
Stewart, the movie's themes are very chaste.
Victoria was one of the longest running
antagonists for Bella and the Cullens throughout
the series. In the first film, her mate James is
killed by the Cullens after he attempts to kill
Bella. Victoria managed to slip away amidst all
the chaos, but she came back looking for revenge
in New Moon. During the first two films, Victoria
was portrayed by Rachelle Lefevre, who reportedly
prepared for the role by pretending to be a
cat to match Victoria's agility and demeanor.
When the third film, Eclipse, was announced, it
was assumed Lefevre would reprise her role as
Victoria. However, the part was recast due
to a scheduling conflict between Eclipse's
shooting schedule and Lefevre's commitment
to shooting the movie Barney's Version.
The two films' schedules overlapped
by 10 days, and Summit — the studio
behind the Twilight films — was unable to
change the shoot to accommodate Lefevre.
The role eventually went to Bryce Dallas Howard,
who had previously turned it down because it was
too small a part. Lefevre was understandably
upset by the whole series of events,
but Summit was not willing to
budge in its decision to recast.
The cover of the novel Twilight is a dramatically
lit image of two hands holding an apple. Apples
are traditionally a symbol of the forbidden
fruit of knowledge and, by extension,
desire. Stephenie Meyer also confirmed that
the apple on the book's cover was a deliberate
biblical allusion. Themes of forbidden fruit
are consistent throughout the Twilight series,
and many characters are drawn to or
desire things or people they cannot have.
If you watch closely, actor Robert Pattinson
recreated the now infamous Twilight cover
during a scene in the first film. In the scene,
Bella drops an apple on the floor. The apple then
bounces off Edward's foot and perfectly lands in
his two palms. The whole thing happens in just
a few seconds, but super attentive fans were
able to notice and appreciate this Easter egg.
Since vampires don't sleep,
it only makes sense for Edward Cullen to break
into Bella's house and watch her sleep, right?
"Do you do that a lot?"
"Just the last couple of months"
Edward encroaching on Bella's privacy rubbed
some people the wrong way when they first
encountered the series as teens. As adults, we
surely see his actions as straight-up creepy
and gross. It would be weird if
they were already in a relationship,
but they weren't even dating at this
point! This is often the first bit of
evidence given when discussing how unsettling
Edward's behavior is throughout the series.
Robert Pattinson's film depiction of Edward
doesn't exactly help his ominous image either,
as he spent most of the first Twilight
film staring intently at his love interest.
Bella reads Edward's mannerisms as mysterious,
and they inspired millions of teenage
readers to fall in love with him. However,
it goes without saying that if he were a real
person he'd be covered in giant red flags.
He's also super possessive and controlling of
Bella, consistently leaving her out of major
points of decision-making in their relationship.
When Bella is attacked by a fellow member
of Edward's coven, he decides for her that
their relationship is too dangerous for her.
Rather than letting Bella assess and accept any
risks for herself, Edward puts the situation
solely in his control, which ultimately ends
up sending her into a depressive spiral.
The anatomy of vampires in the Twilight
films is pretty straightforward.
Their skin is impervious to sharp
objects, they sparkle in direct
sunlight, and they don't have
blood running through their veins.
The only thing supposedly sharp enough
to break vampire skin is vampire teeth,
which are used throughout the Twilight films
as weapons against enemy vampires -- and
as medical instruments in Breaking Dawn.
So if vampire skin cannot be broken, how does
James have a tattoo in the first Twilight film?
While fans may not have thought about it
too much when they became obsessed with
the films for the first time, it definitely
doesn't make sense upon closer inspection.
If a scalpel couldn't break a
vampire's skin in Breaking Dawn,
a tattoo needle definitely wouldn't
be able to place ink in the skin.
The answer to this mystery is pretty
straightforward: the actor who portrayed James,
Cam Gigandet, has a tattoo, and the film
didn't think it was necessary to cover it up.
James' tattoo wasn't exactly an important
element to his part of the story,
so the creators of the film
just decided to let it slide.
There's a lot going on in Breaking Dawn: Part 2,
but there definitely should have been more
screen time devoted to discussing how Jacob,
Bella's longtime friend and former love
interest, imprinted on her newborn baby.
"You nicknamed my daughter
after the Loch Ness Monster!!?"
A lot of Jacob fans simply wrote
his newfound protectiveness
and bond with Renesmee off as romantic,
but there's a bit more to it than that.
Jacob's reveal that Bella's baby is
his soulmate is a moment that's been
the subject of countless memes and analysis,
but a lot of people who watched the films as
teens have even more questions about this plot
twist now as adults. Even if Renesmee grows up
faster than normal humans, wouldn't Jacob
be essentially grooming her from childhood?
What's the exact science behind imprinting? Why
doesn't anyone else in the Cullen clan see any
major issues with this? Does Renesmee have any
agency in this huge part of her life at all?
In the films, Jacob's imprinting on Renesmee is
kind of just explained away by attributing it to
ambiguous werewolf idiosyncrasies. That might
have been enough for teenagers watching the
film the first time, but definitely would earn
more scrutiny from those same viewers today.
While Stephenie Meyer was a household name by the
time the first Twilight film flooded movie screens
worldwide, not too many people were familiar with
Meyer's physical appearance. Little did fans know
that they could easily find the creator of their
favorite series right within the film adaptations.
Towards the end of Twilight, there's a scene where
Bella and her father are eating at the local Forks
diner. The camera pans past a woman sitting
at the diner counter typing away at a laptop.
Super attentive fans were able to recognize
this anonymous writer as Stephenie Meyer,
but it was subtle enough that more
casual viewers might have missed it.
Meyer also had a second cameo in Breaking Dawn:
Part 1, during Bella and Edward's wedding. The
wedding scene had huge hype leading up to the
film's release, and when Bella walks down the
aisle, you can see Stephenie Meyer standing among
all the other wedding guests at the ceremony.
Although Stephenie Meyer said she had to be
talked into participating in the film shoots,
her fans probably appreciated seeing
their favorite author on screen.
According to the world of
Twilight, keeping the existence
of vampires secret is crucial to
any vampire's survival. The Volturi,
a large coven of Vampires who reside in
Italy, are recognized as the official
leaders of vampire society and enforce the
rules that are used to maintain secrecy.
Vampires in the Twilight universe are expected
to follow the coven's laws, and those who break
the rules are typically punished with death.
Such rules include avoiding direct sunlight,
since vampire skin would sparkle and quickly
draw the attention of any humans nearby.
However, despite the Cullens
carefully adapting their lifestyle
to keep a relatively low profile within
Forks, there are still plenty of times
where a reasonable person should have
noticed that something was a little off.
For example, while the Cullens explain to
Bella that they settled in Forks because of
how constantly rainy and cloudy the climate is,
there are still a few times that the vampires
were exposed to direct sunlight in front of other
humans. When Bella sees the Cullens for the first
time, they all sit down at a cafeteria table
together by a window, where a tiny bit of sun
filters in through the glass. In this moment, you
can see a bit of light on Alice's arm. You'd think
that for people whose lives depend on avoiding
the sun they'd sit further away from windows.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Twilight
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.